texas is gearing up for what could be
its largest surge at the border as 60
000 migrants are expected to reach the
state within just the next few weeks one
former border official sounding the
alarm on where they're coming from and
what's driving them to the u.s
the result of that is the message goes
out and then instead of having
a couple of hundred encounters a day we
quickly went up to about six thousand a
little bit of misleading messaging in
the in the public today too is they
think this is just mexico or south
america
border patrol caught over caught people
from 150 different countries coming
through mexico into the united states
the real thing that's changed is the
focus on border security in general and
acknowledging that border security is
critical to homeland security the
messaging has changed
thomas feely is a former ice field
office director for buffalo new york and
he joins us now good morning to you
thomas thanks for being here
good morning ainsley thanks for having
me what are your biggest concerns you
have so much experience with this what
are your what are your concerns
well just like the previous guests just
stated you know a lot of people think
it's just mexicans or people from
central and south america that are
coming across the border and that's
simply not true
a ton of terrorist people uh people who
are nationally security interests are
coming across the border
and we just don't know who they are we
don't know where they're going or what
they're up to and i can tell you right
now i've talked to some people yesterday
and this morning
morale is at an all-time low and it's
just people really need to be concerned
about the border yeah the border patrol
agents are completely overwhelmed what
are your friends down there on the
border saying specifically
they're overwhelmed like i said morale
is in the dirt you know they're they're
trying to do the best job they can
unfortunately you know love of country
only goes so far
they know this administration doesn't
have their back they need more resources
and they're all asking you know why did
we change what we're doing prior to
january this you know our security
ainsley shouldn't be a political issue
and this is really putting all americans
at risk what's your reaction to what
mayor has said he says that he's proud
of what's happening down on the border
what he's doing down there and even if
he could throw all of them out he
wouldn't
it's bizarre you know here you have the
secretary of homeland security that's
watching our border be overrun and he's
okay with it and he's proud of it like
he said those are his words you can't
take them back
and it's just you know we see on tv the
the illegal aliens crossing the border
but what you're not seeing is the amount
of drugs like fentanyl
that are killing our kids and our
brothers and our sisters and it's just
it's rolling across the border and it's
sad that nobody wants to do anything in
this administration how is this all
going to play out in the next election
because if you talk to some critics of
joe biden they feel like they're being
taxed to death they're being told what
their kids are learning in school
they're being told they have to get
vaccinated they have to wear masks in
schools yet these illegal immigrants who
joe biden wants to put through college
for free on your tax dollar dime they
just feel completely abandoned by the
administration how's this going to play
out in the election
you know hopefully it plays out in some
way right i mean this really needs to
stop being a democrat republican issue
and be an american issue you're putting
our lives at risk you're putting our
children's lives at risk and we all know
when our family members get killed by an
illegal alien nobody really cares until
it's the right family and this has got
to stop this has got to stop being a
partisan issue it's got to be taken
seriously the democrats republicans
somebody please stand up for our country
secure the border so we can take care of
letting the people that need our help
into the country because ainsley right
now the fact is so many illegal aliens
have entered the country since january
ice ero who's in charge of finding these
people and making sure they go to court
will never catch up what about
afghanistan i mean it's taken over by
the taliban are we worried should we be
worried about taliban trying to get
through our southern border
absolutely i mean you know one of the
the bases in new jersey is where we're
sending the afghans to be vetted and you
know they came across terrorist
individuals there that were you know of
great concern to why they got here and
how they got here and i think the
numbers were out of all the afghans that
came into new jersey only three percent
of all of them were actually translators
in helping our government so you know
here we're just exporting horrible
people into our country and turning a
blind eye that is so scary especially
when we read reports it's being reported
that some of these refugees are being
able to leave these bases or these posts
and take ubers and go out into the into
the rest of the country
right and you know most americans that i
talk to because i'm one of them you know
we get it people want to come to the
country we want them to do it the right
way you know we have the statute of
liberty we'll help you with open arms
but we've got to have a way to stop
people who don't belong here and that
are only coming here to do us harm we
got to get them out of the country
thomas thank you for all your service
over the years and for coming on thank
you thank you ainsley god bless you're
welcome god bless you hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now